un accueil positif dans l'ensemble je
vous le disais à commencer par les
intéressés c'est à dire les responsables
du privé et du public qui affiche est
une prudente satisfaction dès que le
texte fut connu le poids de leurs
réactions tout comme de celle des
leaders politiques avec pierre-alain la
démarche adoptée est moins ambitieuse
que la précédente et elle ne risque
d'inquiéter personnes de ne pas
provoquer un espèce de débat fratricide
pour georges marchais qui parle d
formidable pression exercée par la
droite les nouvelles propositions du
gouvernement constitue un recul pour
l'opposition il y à ouverture je dirais
qu'il y à une coexistence pacifique
possible mais qu'il y a encore beaucoup
de chemin à faire et que cela dépendra
beaucoup de l'état d'esprit dans lequel
cela se fera du côté de l'église
monseigneur vilnai considère que les
décisions prises favorise une solution
dans le sens de l'apaisement
satisfaction également des parents du
privé je ne dis pas que nous avons gagné
sur tous les points
jeudi cependant que les familles par
leur grande mobilisation ont su imposer
la réseau qui est celle de la pluralité
des cols dans notre pays
c'est un texte d'apaisement dit aussi le
chanoine guiberteau avec cependant une
réserve il manque encore des
éclaircissements
même analyse chez les parents du laïc
cet ensemble de propositions va dans le
bon sens et j'aurais tendance à les
considérer comme positive pour ceux dont
elle traite etc car elle ne traite pas
de l'ensemble de la question